Captain Marvel is one of Marvel Comics
most aspirational figures and has
inspired a passionate fan base but when
a character has been around for this
long there are bound to be some unknown
corners at their history even for
longtime fans it's hard to find a
superhero identity that hasn't been held
by multiple people at some point from
Batman to Thor it's just part of the
territory when it comes to shaking up
the status quo so it's no surprise that
carol danvers is far from the first
person to bear the mantle of Captain
Marvel the first Captain Marvel was an
alien named Marvel a member of the Kree
species who was initially sent to earth
to observe it as a spy disguising
himself as a human scientist named
Walter Lawson he eventually took up the
identity of a superhero to protect the
very people he'd been sent to observe
but Marvel died in 1982 succumbing to
cancer as part of Marvel's first graphic
novel after the death of the first
Captain Marvel the name was passed on to
Monica Rambeau a New Orleans native who
developed a variety of powers after
being exposed to extra dimensional
energy despite having little to do with
the original Captain Marvel she spent
some time using the name as a member of
the Avengers even serving as the team's
leader at one point after Monica the
name made its way back to two of
Marvel's descendants a man named genus
Val and then a woman named phyla fell
all the while Carol Danvers was working
in the wings as Miss Marvel with an
origin story that tied her directly to
Marvel and his power set it wasn't until
2012 that she advanced to take the name
Captain Marvel for herself putting her
in the company of a rich legacy of
heroes from as far back as the earliest
days of Clark Kent it's been tricky for
superheroes to balance personal
relationships with their professional
responsibilities look at Peter Parker
whose life has constantly gone downhill
thanks to the balancing act he has to
play a Spider Man Carol Danvers
situation was even worse for a period of
time miss Marvel wasn't so much Carol
Danvers a secret identity as it was a
completely separate independent
personality after an encounter with a
Creed of ice called the psyche magnetron
fused her human DNA with the alien
Marvel she developed superpowers but at
first she wasn't consciously aware of
them
when her powers kicked in Carol blacked
out and Miss Marvel took over
it took some help from the
interdimensional being Hecate to get her
two identities under control but
whatever it took it was worth it it's
way easier to be a superhero if you can
remember what you did the next day prove
you not a scroll house crow cannot do
that while she was introduced as working
on the same Air Force Base as Marvel
Miss Marvel's solo series took her away
from the military and into the slightly
less demanding field of professional
writing she quickly lands a position as
an editor under Jay jonah Jameson The
Daily Bugle publisher who's always
giving grief to Peter Parker Carol is
brought on by Jameson as an editor of a
women's interest magazine the content of
which the two butted heads over the
cigar-chomping Jameson expected fashion
tips and housekeeping advice while
Carroll wanted to push the publication
as a progressive platform for women the
plot line established Carroll is a
character with an agenda and a
competence to pursue it her champion of
women's rights reflected the era's
ideals of empowerment and liberation
writer Kelly sue Taconic who introduced
Carroll as the new Captain Marvel in
2012 said of the debut series I'm struck
now by how overtly progressive it was
even by today's standards it took
decades for Carroll to become a captain
but she's been a superhero since the
late 70s and not always as Miss Marvel
either binary carol's second superhero
identity came about after an encounter
with rogue a power sapping member of the
x-men who temporarily stripped Carroll
of her creep hours she was later subject
to experimentation by aliens known as
the brute the results of which left her
able to get back into the superhero
action by drawing on the power of a
literal star during this period she lost
her emotional ties to earth leaving her
free to venture into outer space for new
adventures often as an ally of the x-men
by the late 90s she was angling back
toward her original skillset losing her
connection to her cosmic binary powers
and taking on the alias of war bird and
fighting as a member of the Avengers but
the loss of her binary powers brought
Carroll to a personal low at her worst
she developed a drinking habit and
became professionally unreliable with
her conduct eventually leading to her
pension from the team afterwards she
spent a few years as more of a
background character before returning to
prominence and her old name with a
second Miss Marvel Series in 2006 but as
dark as those days were for Carroll
becoming an alcoholic and getting kicked
off the Avengers is far from the worst
thing that's happened to her superhero
stories can take their characters to
some weird places but one plot turned
from Carroll's past was so twisted that
it nearly ruined her as a character it
all took place in a single-issue
1980s Avengers number 200 only three
years after Carole had made her debut as
Miss Marvel it's now widely considered
to be one of the worst comic books ever
written in the story The Avengers
discover that Miss Marvel has become
pregnant under mysterious circumstances
that in itself isn't a problem
just ask Carole's friends Spider Woman
the bizarre part is that the entire
nine-month development of her pregnancy
takes course over just a few days
resulting in a child who ages and an
impossibly fast rate the baby quickly
grows into a man named Marcus who
explains that he was previously trapped
in an alternate dimension called limbo a
world without time in which he was born
he only escaped limbo by being born
again through Miss Marvel things turned
from bizarre to frightening when Marcus
reveals that he actually kidnapped
Carole subjecting her to several weeks
worth of manipulation and mind-control
after which he impregnated her with his
essence and erased her memory of the
event to call this development creepy is
a serious understatement Tanika instead
of throwing him into the Sun Carole is
written as developing romantic feelings
for the interdimensional sex criminal
who is also her son deciding to leave
The Avengers to go back to his world
with him making things even worse
Carole's teammates don't see anything
wrong with any of it as writer and
artist Carole Strickland wrote in an
essay criticizing the issue the entire
plot is a deadly insult to every woman
fortunately for Carole's legacy the
bizarre story was effectively retcon the
next year by writer Chris Claremont who
previously wrote for the Miss Marvel
solo series Claremont took great pains
to fix the mess this story left making
it clear that Carole didn't fall in love
with her attacker but was instead
washed and when she's rescued from
Marcus's clutches
she takes the Avengers to task with
righteous fury for standing by and doing
nothing while she fell into the villains
grasp it's hard to imagine Netflix's
Jessica Jones without Trish Walker but
Trish wasn't the first character
intended to fill the supporting role the
original plans for the show included
none other than Carol Danvers as
Jessica's best friend
considering Carol's history of
intergalactic adventures her inclusion
would have made for quite a different
show or at least a very stripped-down
version of Carol
now that Netflix's Marvel partnership
has come to an end it's probably for the
best that Carol stayed on the film side
of the equation after all Captain Marvel
once fought off an entire fleet of
spaceships single-handedly and that's
the kind of thing that begs to be seen
in a movie
her powers are big budgets once that
Hawkeye ever do that compares to that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorites topper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]